Salut, si vous suivez la chaîne ou si vous avez vu cette vidéo
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que j'ai deux trophées Youtube
Un que j'ai eu légalement
Et un autre que j'ai eu ...euh... moins légalement
Mais le fait est que ce sont deux trophés originaux
et qu'aujourd'hui je vous donne l'occasion d'en gagner un des deux
Mais pour ça, va falloir faire chauffer vos neurones
alors, générique
Restez bien jusqu'à la fin de la vidéo
Je vais vous donner des informations importantes pour gagner le trophée et deux rendez-vous
Pour essayer de gagner le trophée, que je vous l'envoie ou qu'on se rencontre
J'ai créé une énigme depuis plusieurs semaines
Vous pouviez déjà essayer de résoudre quelques indices
Je vais maintenant lancer une vidéo de 30 secondes
Cette vidéo de 30 secondes, C'EST l'énigme!
C'est l'énigme finale pour recevoir le trophée
Ecoutez la bien. Détaillez la bien.
Et on se retrouve juste après pour quelques informations supplémentaires
Vous êtes prêts? alors c'est parti
ça a été un petit peu rapide peut-être?
Je vous conseille quand même de la regarder soit en slow
Soit de revenir en arrière
En tout cas prenez le temps de la dépouiller
de la dépiauter même
Elle-même fait référence à trois vidéos qui sont déjà passées sur la chaîne
Et dans la finalité de cette énigme , vous allez vous retrouvez face à 10 liens
Dans ces 10 liens il y a un formulaire
La fin de l'énigme c'est de répondre à ce formulaire
Mais!
Si vous répondez à deux formulaires différents
Et ça on le saura avec le nom, le prénom , ou le mail, ou le code postal, ou l'adresse IP
Alors vous êtes automatiquement disqualifiés
Vous ne devez et ne pouvez répondre qu'à un seul formulaire
C'est une condition sinéquanone
ça veut dire que quand vous répondez
c'est que vous êtes sûr d'être au bon endroit
Comment on va savoir qui a gagné?
Eh bien c'est très simple
Je vais prendre les 100 premiers à avoir répondu juste
Et parmi ces personnes qui ont réussi je prendrai quelqu'un au sort
ça veut dire que la rapidité rentre en ligne de compte
IL faut absolument faire partie des 100 premiers à trouver
Mais la où vous avez de la chance; même si la rapidité rentre en compte
C'est que c'est pas si simple à trouver, je suis même pas sûr qu'il y ait 100 personnes qui vont trouver
je sais pas
Vous pouvez aussi vous organiser à plusieurs d'ailleurs
Bref ! Je tirerai donc une personne au sort et je ferai une vidéo
où je vous expliquerai toutes les réponses de toute l'énigme générale
et des sous-énigmes et de tous les indices
et en même temps j'annoncerai pour la première fois je le ferai pas avant,
le nom du gagnant ou de la gagnante
Donc le seul moyen de savoir qu'on a gagné ou pas ce sera de regarder la vidéo réponse
Je vous donne également 2 rendez-vous avant qu'on se quitte
le premier rendez-vous c'est le 2 mai à 18h
pour un FAQ live
mais à destination principalement des créateurs et des vidéastes
ça existe au Etats-Unis depuis pas mal de temps
et Youtube a décidé de le faire pour la première fois en France
Et j'ai l'honneur d"être le premier invité
Donc si vous êtes créateurs, si vous êtes vidéastes
ou si vous voulez simplement participer à ça
Je vous mets un lien dans le description. Ce sera donc en live, en streaming
Ce qui m'amène au 2e rendez-vous
Je vais refaire un live , un petit peu comme on a fait l'autre jour sur la chaîne
Si vous n'avez pas vu, j'ai mis la vidéo là quelque part
On a joué ensemble à un jeu d'énigme mais c'était vraiment interractif et très participatif
durant un petit peu moins d'une heure
J'ai adoré ça! Je crois apparemment que ça vous a plus aussi
donc je vais en remettre un en place
Je l'annoncerai sur Twitter, sur Insta et sur Facebook
N'hésitez pas à me rajouter vous avez les liens dans la description
Je cois que j'ai TOUT dit! Maintenant il va falloir chercher
quelle est la réponse à cette énigme
Et je vous donne rendez-vous très bientôt
Ciao!